obviously this is a very very complex
issue that is extremely heated but of
course it is now on the Forefront as US
Special Forces are offering assistance
over the hostages who have been taken by
Hamas which Biden says many may be
American citizens of course there was a
carrier group dispatched and fears that
this could escalate into a more serious
conflict and if we're seeing conflict
now escalating to the point of us or
other countries mobilizing you know
maybe we're we're we're at the point
where we might World War III they've
been saying that about Ukraine for some
time now but when we get you know
Conflict at this level in various
regions if China then moves on Taiwan
things get really really bad so